I've already referred to shutting down
of restaurants and schools slow closing
etcetera that speaks to how it affects
the individuals that we're trying to
help here I'm chairman of the Finance
Committee as my colleagues and all I've
been working with my colleagues around
the clock to find opportunities and the
tax code to reduce stress on American
taxpayers and the businesses that create
the jobs and the businesses that are
probably closed now and they're laker
workers laid off our small group of
people or a small group of colleagues
working to help the American taxpayers
and the businesses so the jobs are
continued we first adopted a do no harm
approach we want to ensure that routine
government processes don't add to the
strain that everybody has out there we
do this by issuing recovery assistance
to American families in the form of
checks that can go out the door in a
short order these direct payments could
be as much as $1,200 for individuals 20
for $400 for couples with additional
assistance to families obviously the
purpose of this is to provide immediate
relief to folks who are facing cash flow
problems in their families as they stay
home to stop the spread of this virus to
avoid in-person meetings with tax
preparers in the midst of the pandemic
we're extending the tax filing deadline
from April the 15th to July the 15th and
of course we all know the administration
is already deferred collection of taxes
until I think July or late
so this will help families defer filing
costs and avoid meetings that could put
folks at risk at this time of who knows
how far the effect of this virus is
going to be the deadline for quarterly
estimated tax payments will also be povo
postponed for 100 days we encourage
those able to land a financial hand by
providing additional deductions for
charitable giving this includes
suspending the deduction limitation for
cash donations by individuals and easing
the limitation on donations of cash and
food inventories by businesses
additionally for those who do not
itemize a new deduction will be
available for everyone who gives
regardless of how you file your taxes
American businesses as we know are the
engine of our economy and we stand ready
to help them as well American business
men and women are our job providers and
we need to make sure that they can keep
their doors open or if those doors are
closed today to reopen them and the
payrolls that they have going out to
those individual workers and families
across the nation can be maintained our
proposal includes items to improve cash
flow and liquidity for businesses of all
sizes businesses including the
self-employed will be able to defer
their quarterly tax estimates 180 days
and their employers Social Security tax
payments through 2020 we're going to
increase the limit on interest
deductibility will speed up the recovery
of the alternative minimum tax credits
and we'll relax limitations on how
companies use losses from previous years
to reduce their tax burdens these are
just some of the many provisions and our
proposal to unburden businesses
particularly those that have liquidity
problems so that they can keep employing
those who are home earning for their
families and helping to prospective en't
the spread of the virus and I hope
nobody tries to tell me or the rest of
us that we're bailing out business we
are in the job of preserving jobs or if
those jobs have been lost in the last 10
days because of this slowdown of the
economy almost the shutdown of the
economy then we want those jobs to be
brought back workers are employed
because of government's decisions not
the employers decision not the employees
lack of hard work because federal state
and local governments have stopped
interaction among people so that we
don't spread this virus and it's because
of what the World Health Organization
has labeled were world health pandemic
we don't see it as bad now as we do in
Italy in other countries of Europe we
hope we don't see it as bad as they have
but we just don't know and because we
don't know people have this anxiety they
don't know about the future and we ought
to give some help to the future so I
describe to you some of the things that
the Finance Committee is working on I've
also joined senator Alexander and others
to assist healthcare workers and
patients this portion of the package
includes several finance committee
provisions to help everyone fight the
pandemic for example we're adding
additional flexibility to the health
savings accounts bolstering telehealth
services and boosting Medicare payments
to health care providers we can contain
this deadly virus without destroying the
livelihoods of Nations economies but
right now our constituents have doubt
about that and this proposal that the
leader is put forth is to try to quiet
some of that anxiety these
recommendations take bold steps to curb
the economic fallout as we work as a
country to contain this pandemic these
proposals won't be the end of the
Congressional response to coral karana
virus I think we made that clear that
this is a third effort
- already signed by the president United
States and they'll probably be more and
when people want more than what's maybe
here there's going to be plenty of
opportunities
for more I wish I could say we know by a
certain date that this anxiety is going
to go away and we know that this
pandemic has slowed down enough that we
can go back to work and started
interacting with our kin with our
friends and family to the same extent we
always have and open up the restaurants
I stand ready to continue identifying
targeted relief as necessary to help
bridge the gap beyond this bill but we
need to take this next step and do it
quickly
I want to thank leader McConnell for
convening our task forces to quickly
provide meaningful relief to families
individuals and all sectors the economy
the people I've been working with that I
thank our senators John Thune Rob
Portman Pat Toomey Tim Scott Tom cotton
Mitt Romney for working with me on this
package some of those members are
hardworking members of the Finance
Committee and some aren't on the
committee because we wanted as broad of
an opinion as we could I know our staffs
work literally around the talk so I want
to recognize their efforts as well so
many Americans are working day and night
to provide essential services and and
and efforts to combat this outbreak we
in Congress must be prepared to do the
same and that's why you heard the leader
a little while ago saying that we're
going to stay in until we get this job
done we ought to applaud that type of
leadership it's a commitment to keep the
center open until we've done our part
and I look forward to working with
Democrats and the administration to get
this job done without delay so maybe if
we work hard Friday Saturday and Sunday
we can get a bill to the president
next week nobody should be going home
until we've delivered this needed relief
we all often spoke in World War two
about the United States being the
arsenal of democracy still remember as
only nine years old December the 7th
1941 and then don't remember at the time
but studying history you remember how we
ramped up productions for the war effort
can we ramp up production of the
respirators protective gears and testing
kits we need can we do it on the same
scale we did in World War two a scale
that can help us overcome this crisis
and I suppose you all remember this the
cry of remember Pearl Harbor to help us
pull the country together to win that
war can we think of kind of remember
coronavirus as an effort to pull this
country together because in that in
those times I remember we all pulled
together to let's say just one example
we all prided ourselves and planning
what we call Victory Gardens we did it
in a unison as we sought to defeat the
Axis powers can we pull together in the
same way to sow the spread of kovat
nineteen til our healthcare system
catches up with something that we never
anticipated never could plan for I think
this is a test of America's character
just like it was a test of our character
in World War two to pull together I
yield the floor
mr. president Democratic leader well
thank you mr. president and I'm glad now
that the Republican leader and his
caucus now have a plan and we look
forward to working with them to come up
with a bipartisan product as soon as we
can because this crisis grows worse
every day and we believe we need a bold
plan a strong plan our plan must put
workers the millions of workers who are
adversely affected by this crisis first
it includes service and industry workers
gig workers freelancers bartenders
retail workers airline attendants so
many others our plan is entitled workers
first first and foremost we owe so much
gratitude to the hard-working people of
America and many of them are in trouble
now through no fault of their own this
virus has affected some of them has
required others to be quarantined and
has caused businesses to layoff millions
we must protect them
first and foremost and so our plan has
five basic pillars pillar one is to
bolster the health care system
dramatically if we don't beat the fight
against this virus if we don't do it as
quickly as possible the economy will get
worse and worse no matter what we do so
we must work extremely quickly and
massively to bolster our health care
system we need a Marshall Plan for our
health care system and that is what we
propose we need direct aid to hospitals
the larger hospitals in many cities
already have patients many patients in
their beds
the smaller and rural hospitals could
well be in danger of closing because of
this crisis we must bolster the
hospital's they need a
they need ventilators they need more ICU
beds they need masks a simple thing like
a nose swab a hospital told me that they
can't do testing because they don't have
the nasal swabs and we need the
president to marshal the DPA the defense
production Act to get all of these
materials produced on a wartime footing
quickly dramatically and in large number
our first plank of our plan dramatically
bolsters our health care system which is
being overwhelmed through no fault of
the hard-working people there in this
crisis and it entails so much health
care workers have to be able to get to
the hospitals to the nursing homes to
the other areas in many places they
can't if there isn't the kind of transit
public transit that is available and is
now not working the second part of our
plan deals directly with those who have
lost income through no fault of their
own it is a dramatic bolstering of
unemployment insurance we call it either
unemployment insurance on steroids we
call it unemployment insurance on
steroids or you might even call it
employment insurance if a worker loses
his or her job through no fault of their
own
right now unemployment insurance doesn't
cover a whole lot of people when it does
it doesn't pay them much in terms of
salary in terms of a percentage of
income and it's often hard to get and
takes a long time our unemployment on
steroids
our employment insurance provides a full
amount of the wages that workers are not
being paid not 20 percent or 50 percent
people desperately need it it is quick
and easy to apply for without all these
hurdles that are now put in the way and
it applies to many more workers than in
the past we have talked to business
owners large medium and small for many
of them this is the
number one thing they need while they
can't keep their workers on the payroll
because no money is coming in these
workers will still be there they'll be
furloughed they'll be getting a full
salary and when the businesses come back
they will be back the third part of our
plan is for paid leave we must have paid
family leave we must have paid sick
leave Cova too did some of that but too
many people are not covered and too many
people are not covered in a strong
longer-term way senators Murray
Gillibrand
working with the house have put together
a very strong package we must have it in
this proposal forth I believe no one's
seen the proposal where I haven't seen
and I think anyone has seen the proposal
that the leader put on it had virtually
no input from Democrats but we will look
at it and read it tonight but from what
I'm told it provides a bailout for a
number of industries again we have to
put the workers first we don't want
these industries to go under but we
certainly don't want the dollars that
are put there to go to corporate
executives or shareholders again they
must go to the workers first if they're
getting a bailout they should not cut
the number of workers the salary of
workers the benefits of workers the
pensions of workers and none of this
money should be used for corporate
buybacks I am outraged that the airline
industry in the last five years spent
about forty billion dollars on buybacks
they're now saying they don't have
enough money had they not sent the money
to the shareholders and had it there or
used it to bolster their workforces that
might not have happened nor should the
money go to corporate salaries or
corporate gain
part four of our plan says no bailout
that goes to the people at the top the
money should go to the workers after all
that's who we want to protect every one
of us knows workers in these industries
they're hardworking decent honorable
people and fift help for small business
small businesses suffer the little
restaurant maybe it's the small
manufacturing business maybe it's a
little service business they need help
their employees should they have to
furlough them will be taken care of by
our employment insurance but they still
have other costs we've called for
forbearance in mortgages that's a big
cost that they will continue to maintain
if they rent space but they will need
help with other costs and we provide the
money for those costs with the view that
that money could be those loans could be
forgiven if they rehire all their
workers once they're back on their feet
so five points and I know that the
Speaker of the House agrees with these
points the House Democrats agree with
these points and unfortunately the
leader didn't want them included in
negotiation which can only prolong the
length of time before we act but so be
it one a Marshall Plan for our health
care system and our hospitals to
employment insurance you lose your job
you get your pay three paid leave paid
family leave paid sick leave for any
bailouts must be worker first and five
help for small business we need to act
quickly we need to act in a bipartisan
way
I hope the discussions between the
various members of the committee will
proceed quickly and in a spirit of
compromise and I hope
that we can come to quick agreement with
the house whose use are much the
majority's views are much closer to ours
than this document which I haven't read
but I've heard things about I haven't
seen it mr. president this is a crisis
like none we have seen we don't know how
long it'll last
we don't know how many people will be
affected we do know it's getting worse
every day
and we know also that when while
Americans usually come together after a
crisis New Yorker certainly do as we did
after 9/11 we now must be isolated but
we will prevail we will prevail we will
work together hopefully each side will
give we will come up with a good plan we
will send it to the president and we
will help to begin the long path to
eradicate this awful virus that has so
afflicted so many millions of Americans
in one way or another I yield the floor
mr. president senator from Mississippi
mr. president I agree with so much of
what the distinguished Democratic leader
has just said and I was coming from one
building you know to the other when the
distinguished senator from Iowa was
speaking but I know he was making the
points that that I would I would make at
this time too if the distinguished
Democratic leader wants to call this a
Marshall Plan for the coronavirus crisis
I will subscribe to that I think it's
that serious and I agree with with what
the Democratic leader said about this
economic crisis it's something like
we've never seen before and it calls for
dramatic action and I think that's what
the majority leader Senator McConnell
has proposed
and and I agree with this from my friend
from New York when we try to rescue the
large corporations we need to put
workers first and and not be concerned
about the CEOs and the executives we
need to take care of small business so
let's do a Marshall Plan and let's do it
on a bipartisan basis as Americans
because this economic crisis knows no
parties you know in some instances when
there's a crisis we're told to carry on
and in this case that really isn't what
the health-care professors have told
Americans to do Americans are have been
told and people around the world have
been told to stay at home don't
congregate well that's the way our
economy operates so Americans are doing
what they've been asked to do we're not
flying we're not staying in hotels I can
put seas down to single digits
restaurants are closed stores are closed
Americans are keeping their children
home from school schools are not open
even in most areas again the American
people are acting responsibly according
to what they have been told to do by
health professionals the public is
taking guidance and this is having an
enormous toll on our economy
we hope the virus will end soon but we
need a rescue package and I'm happy to
join with a distinguished Democratic
leader and calling it a Marshall Plan if
you'd like to do it the American people
bear no responsibility for this act of
nature this act of god that has
overtaken much of the globe and so I
come here today to say I've been honored
to participate
in the drafting of what Senator
McConnell the distinguished majority
leader has rolled out today the the
coronavirus economic stabilization act
and I was part of a task force that the
that the distinguished majority leader
asked us to work on that task force
dealt with the airline industry
it consisted of chairman Shelby and the
Majority Whip soon and we're happy to
develop a plan that involves two hundred
eight billion dollars giving the
Secretary of the Treasury the ability to
provide loans and loan guarantees to
eligible businesses that are enduring
financial hardship including the
domestic airlines including the domestic
cargo carriers if they can make the case
that there's a hardship there during
this time of unprecedented economic
uncertainty it's critical that the
airlines and other impacted industries
have the resources they need to continue
operations vital to the transportation
of passengers and supplies including
food including medical equipment mr.
president
the plan that I participated in drafting
in which the distinguished majority
leader put forward a day would prohibit
the federal funds from being used to
increase compensation or provide golden
parachutes of that sort of thing for the
leaders of these distressed companies so
again I subscribed to what Senator
Schumer said protect the workers this is
no bailout
this is jobs and this is jobs
this is loans that we expect to be paid
back when times are flush again this
legislation would take an important step
in putting our economy back on track
for the American people
a great deal of work has gone into the
draft and much work is going to be
required in the future tonight tomorrow
tomorrow night Saturday and Sunday we're
in the midst of a severe economic crisis
and I'm determined to work on a
bipartisan basis with people like my
friend who just spoke with Senator
Cantwell the senator from Washington my
distinguished ranking member we have
penciled in 10:00 a.m. tomorrow morning
I've already been on the phone with her
and we're going to we are going to be
dealing with our with with the
legislation under the jurisdiction of
our committee the Commerce Committee and
I think we're going to be able to work
as we have on so many other issues as
Americans and not as Republicans
Democrats as teammates rising to the
occasion answering this crisis as
Americans have done so many times in the
past and and so I I simply rise today to
say this is this is a time for us to
come together as Patriots as Americans
and take on the task that is before us I
look forward to a hard weekend of work
and a product that all Americans can be
proud of and with that I yield the floor
mr. president
mr. president I suggest the absence of a
quorum
the clerk will call the roll mr.
Alexander
mr. president senator from Florida I
asked that the quorum call be suspended
without objection
mr. president we in this profession have
a tendency to hyperbole meaning a
tendency to stand sometimes and talk
about how dramatic a decision we're
about to make is or how important
something is to the country because
that's what we do
and it's sort of one of the tools of
this trade I think this is not a time in
which it's possible to